let's start today with a positive story
that reminds us that sometimes sometimes
activism and media pressure
can actually have an effect a nancy
pelosi the democratic speaker of the
house has done a complete 180 and she is
now supporting a ban on members of
congress trading individual stocks now
this doesn't mean it's actually going to
happen it doesn't mean it's actually
going to pass it may we'll have to wait
and see
but in just two short months nancy
pelosi not because she wants to
but because she was embarrassed and
pressured into it
has done a complete 180 and has gone
from there's no reason members of
congress should be banned from trading
individual stocks two i'd be open to it
to let's actually go ahead and do it so
as a reminder back in december of last
year just two months ago nancy pelosi
was asked about this and she rejected
the idea of a stock trading ban for
members of congress here's that clip
should members of congress and their
spouses be banned from trading
individual stocks while serving in
congress no i don't know to this second
one um
any uh we have a responsibility to
report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five month
review but if the people aren't
reporting they should be
yeah
because this is a free market in people
we are free market economy they should
be able to participate in that so that
was up in december
then we got to january and in january
nancy pelosi said well
i'm open to a stock trading ban from
congress i have great confidence in the
integrity of my members they are
remarkable
so when people talk about well somebody
might do this and somebody i trust our
members to give a blanket attitude of we
can't do this and we can't do that
because we can't be trusted i don't buy
into that but if members want to do it
i'm okay with that and then the latest
news is that nancy pelosi is now pushing
a stock trading ban for members of
congress axios reporting just hours ago
house speaker nancy pelosi is moving to
ban stock trading on capitol hill after
having consistently opposed such a
measure
this adds unprecedented momentum to an
issue that also has bipartisan support
on the senate side
pelosi's in primiter follows building
momentum in both parties some
progressive democrats and mega
republicans have united on a proposal to
ban sitting lawmakers from trading
individual stocks pelosi who expressed
opposition in the past
and some other democratic leaders have
been slow to take up the issue
despite reported interest from house
minority leader kevin mccarthy so now
the idea as axio says is amend the stock
act from 2012 which governs how members
disclose purchase and sale of stocks to
eliminate the trading of individual
stocks by members of congress this is
very very interesting now this doesn't
mean it will happen
but this is without a doubt the most
momentum we've seen in this direction
and i think it has to be restated again
and again
nancy pelosi doesn't want to do this
nancy pelosi uh notoriously is involved
in individual stock trading
options puts i mean it's been widely
reported
she doesn't want this
but it is because of pressure
and essentially being embarrassed into
having to be open to it that it has
gained momentum and that's something we
all did and some media outlets have been
doing
now this is not
going to be
you know it's it's not
there are some who are opposing this on
the basis that it's some kind of
oppressive authoritarian you know
whatever
um if you
choose
to run for the house or senate
and you know
if i do that i won't be able to trade
individual stocks i can still i can
still hold mutual funds
um i can still own the stocks and put
them in a blind trust this is not super
oppressive guys and it does make perfect
sense because not only are you in a
position
to know ahead of time about
events that could impact stock prices
the way we saw happen in that
crazy couple week period at the start of
the pandemic and we saw senator kelly
leffler and others dumping stocks and
buying stocks and all these different
things on the basis of of what they
presumably
logically were told at some of these
pre-covered briefings it's not just that
you learn about things ahead of time
it's also that your decisions can impact
the prices of stocks now i think if we
really want to be thorough it's
important to say
even without trading stocks if at the
time that you become a member of the
house or senate you know what stocks you
own even if you can't trade them
you can still try to legislate in ways
that would be advantageous to you right
so imagine i enter
the house and i know that i own
i don't know a bunch of stocks of a
bunch of shares of google for just to
make it very very simple
even if i can't trade those while i am
in the house or senate
i could still
push legislation or vote in a way that
would bolster the value of the google
stock i know i have without trading it
so even this which some are saying oh
it's two it's too much it's too
authoritarian it's too crazy it still
leaves itself open to sort of abuse and
manipulation due to the power that
legislators have but it would be a big
deal it would be a big deal and so we're
going to follow whether it actually
happens
it really makes perfect sense many
members of the house and senate are in
favor of it and the truth i i hate to
say this but some of them are in favor
of it because they know that there's
still a bunch of ways around it that
they're going to be able to find
i mean it you know i it's not just
because they uh think it's the right
thing to do and it's not just because
they would get the benefit of optics
it's also because many of them have a
number of different ways around it and
it the devil will be in the details how
is it worded with regard to uh blind
trusts how is it worded with regard to
mutual funds how is it worded with
regard to the spouses or family members
of those in the house and senate you
know nancy pelosi's husband has been a
big um element of focus when it comes to
her stock trading so many details to be
sorted out but it is a very uh it's a
welcome 180 from just two months ago
all right on monday i told you
some states are looking very strongly
at going in the direction
of considering
dropping mass mandates either indoor at
businesses and or
in schools over the last 48 hours since
i came to you with that report it is
accelerating dramatically more and more
localities more and more states talking
about no more masks as of some date in
the relatively near future could be
february could be march and the question
now is is this the right time not
everybody agrees that it is i don't
actually have an answer and so anybody
trying to read into whether i think it's
time to end masking or not i'm not
completely sure i think there's
definitely a discussion to be had let's
go through some of the news um uh wabc
reporting
indoor masking coming to an end in new
york
is it hocal or hotel i never remember
hokel expected to make an announcement
wednesday
it is anticipated that the governor of
new york will announce the end of the
indoor mass mandate in new york state on
wednesday but the city mandate will
remain in place
the state mandate requires mass to be
worn inside businesses where vaccination
status was not being checked it is set
to expire thursday and the new york
times reports that the governor will
rescind it
um
connecticut and new jersey are already
among a handful of states with plans to
ease mass mandates in schools the
governor of new york has not made the
same move
however she held a call with school
superintendents who believe an
announcement is coming soon
the governor is expected to extend the
mass mandate past its february 21st
expiration and through winter break
meanwhile illinois is expected to
announce an end or rollback of certain
mask rules cnn reporting the governors
of new york and illinois are expected to
announce the end of or a plan to roll
back
certain coveted mitigation requirements
involving masks today
i already told you about new york in
illinois governor jb pritzker will
likely announce wednesday a path for
ending the state's indoor mass mandate
in most public places
um
there is also increasingly pressure
in massachusetts on the governor charlie
baker to make some kind of uh off-ramp
type statement
many cities and towns already going in
that direction in california
california's indoor mask mandate will
end next week
for vaccinated people citing a 65
percent drop in covet cases since the
peak of omicron california will end its
statewide indoor mass mandate for
vaccinated individuals next week
governor gavin newsom announced monday
on february 15 california's statewide
indoor mass requirement will expire
unvaccinated people must still wear
masks indoors
less than 20 percent of the state's
population remain unvaccinated according
to data the biden administration has not
yet offered a plan or roadmap for how to
handle this so a couple different things
here number one not everybody agrees
about this one example is the former
surgeon general jerome adams now
jerome adams was not exactly the voice
of reason uh when the donald trump was
president so there are people who would
say
i don't care what jerome adams says but
jerome adams tweeting quote i
respectfully disagree with many of my
colleagues who are espousing the idea
that prematurely dropping mask mandates
will somehow make it easier to bring
them back if and when things get worse
again how'd that work out when cdc said
vaccinated could unmask last summer
he went on to say how do i define
premature well by looking at spread
impact and protection spread
seven day average still highest since
april of last year
impact over 2500 deaths yesterday
protection only 22 percent of those 5 to
11 and 56 of 12 to 17 year olds are
vaccinated exit the highway early trip
takes longer
um i'm not sure if this is the right
thing to do or not
on the one hand jerome adams is right
which is the numbers are still not
looking great
that being said
we know
that the numbers significantly lag what
is going on there are states with cases
down 85 to 90 percent
vaccines are so widely available
the death rate is so incredibly low for
the vaccinated that the there becomes a
question of what is the milestone
and if there is not a reversal if we say
well cases are down in the country about
70 percent
in some states they're down 85 to 90 if
we give it one more month and and that
continues and there isn't a reversal
there really won't be anything else to
wait for in the sense that
it's not going away
anytime soon there's going to be a low
level again if in the next month there's
not a new variant that causes cases to
spike in a month cases will be
really at what we might call an endemic
level doesn't mean that the cases are
mild it might or it might not but we're
talking about the case levels
there's a question of what would we be
waiting for at that point in time
and there's not really a clear answer
and so that's where the if not in two to
four weeks then when
becomes a relevant question
um people who choose to remain
unvaccinated do so at their own risk and
as always the question then becomes what
about the
immunocompromised and um
that is a situation where those folks
say well i've gotten vaccinated
but
i still really can't do anything because
i might still catch it and i'm at higher
risk and that's a serious question i
mean a lot of those people haven't been
doing anything anyway so
it is a sort of chicken egg thing where
if the immuno-compromised folks that
have been staying home all this time
are already staying home
then
what is the reason to delay ending the
mask mandates for those who are not
staying home it's complicated i'm going
to admit that it's very complicated but
the question i keep coming back to is
if not in a month then what is the
milestone that we are waiting for and
i've not heard a good answer to that
which suggests
continuing on with some of this stuff
the school's question is a separate
question
particularly when in schools you've got
a population that has a lower
vaccination rate
um
i'm thinking out loud along with you
guys and i know that in my audience
there are people who are saying
this is it it's time for the personal
responsibility phase end everything and
let people decide for themselves what
level of risk to accept like we do
during flu season some people already
would wear a mask during flu season or
stay home that's one side of my audience
the other side of my audience says do
nothing we need to keep masking for at
least the entire year we should be
closing schools we should so so i know
that there's different sides in my
audience and i'm curious to hear from
you find me on twitter at dpakman and
let me know
what you think should happen now
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
i know most of you probably don't know
this but we are an audience supported
program and i would love it if you
supported us through our membership
program at joinpackman.com
we have
so many great membership perks including
a daily bonus show which alex jones
hates oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad we also
have commercial free audio and video
streams of the show available for our
members every day and you get the show
six hours earlier you know how it
normally at nine pm eastern that day's
full episode is out in video format as a
member you get it at 3 p.m eastern six
hours earlier
stunning stunning stuff and you can sign
up at joinpakman.com
today i report to you
maybe the most extreme salvo in the
republican civil war that we have seen
so far
mitch mcconnell
abandoning the line from the republican
national committee and referring to the
trump riots
as a violent insurrection so far no
response from donald trump but donald
trump for months now has been going
after mitch mcconnell attacking senate
minority leader former majority leader
mitch mcconnell for not doing this
enough and not doing that enough and not
being grateful enough that trump helped
him get reelected and all these
different things
and mitch mcconnell has now come out and
said
january 6 was a violent insurrection
very different language than we've seen
from the rnc as the hill reports senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell
criticized the rnc for its censure of
congress people adam kinzinger and liz
cheney
and broke with their language on the
trump riots calling it a violent
insurrection
violent insurrection
let's take a look at the video here is
mitch mcconnell asked about it and in no
uncertain terms uses language that is
not going to be pleasant for trump or
the rnc
center two city members of congress and
also use the word legitimate political
discourse in talking about january 6.
well let me give you my view of what
happened january the 6th and we all were
here we're here we we saw it happen it
was a violent insurrection
for the purpose of trying to prevent the
peaceful transfer of power
after a legitimately certified election
from one administration to the next
without a doubt who can possibly say
that what mitch mcconnell is saying is
wrong
but mitch mcconnell is no hero right i
mean mitch mcconnell declined to hold
trump accountable in the immediate
aftermath of the event do you guys
remember this
i know it
sort of feels like it was a long time
ago and yet it feels very recent but
remember that when the second trump
impeachment happened remember trump is a
twice impeached former president when
the second impeachment of donald trump
happened mitch mcconnell said listen
uh
trump was responsible
this was what it was it was terrible
but
impeachment
is a limited tool
and trump is not constitutionally
eligible for impeachment conviction he
had the biggest cop-out at the time
where he said well yeah he did it he did
the thing that we're accusing him of
doing
but impeachment can only be used in very
narrow circumstances and this is not one
of those circumstances and so i must
vote against conviction in the second
impeachment of donald trump mcconnell is
pathetic he chose to protect the
republican party instead of doing what
was right for the country at the time
and now he says well yeah it was a
violent insurrection so much like when
george w bush
drunkenly stumble i shouldn't say
drunkenly i know he
used to have an alcohol problem i i met
metaphorically drunkenly stumbles when
george w bush inadvertently stumbles
across the correct take on something
related to trump
we don't say wow what a good guy huh
no it's still war criminal george w bush
it's still the same george w bush that
got us into two wars
and uh one on completely fabricated
intelligence i mean it's still george w
bush and in the same way
we're interested in mitch mcconnell
directly saying it's a violent
insurrection
it was a violent insurrection we're
interested in it because it's completely
at odds with donald trump it is a dodds
with what the republican national
committee uh decided at the recent
meeting and you know at odds with what
they did with uh congressman
kinzinger and congresswoman liz cheney
uh and we're interested in it because it
is fomenting the civil war which
hopefully will be destructive to the
republican party in the midterms that
are now just
barely eight and a half months away
but it's not because we like mitch
mcconnell the guy is pathetic and we
shouldn't forget that
now
the other amazing thing that happened
yesterday
is
the mitch mcconnell clip we looked at
earlier where mitch mcconnell said
january 6 was a violent insurrection
it was a response
to house minority leader republican
kevin mccarthy being asked about january
6 and saying that there was
legitimate political discourse there
this is i i want to make sure you
understand sort of the parallel of
what's going on here um rachel scott
who is the congressional correspondent
for abc news
um asked kevin mccarthy
about whether there was legitimate
political discourse on january 6th and
mccarthy seemed to be saying that there
was okay so here's the original clip
here's the original clip from yesterday
morning i think there was legitimate
political discourse
yeah everybody knows there was anyone
who broke inside
okay
so he says when asked was there a
legitimate political discourse on
january 6. he says yeah everybody
everybody thinks there was
um
uh and and he seems to say even the
people who broke in
he later put out a statement saying no
no no the people who broke in
were not engaging in legitimate
political discourse that is what then
led mitch mcconnell to be asked
this is what kevin mccarthy said what do
you think and mcconnell said it was a
violent insurrection then this goes
nuclear and it goes beyond parody
later in the day
rachel scott goes back to kevin mccarthy
to try to ask again did you really mean
that the rioters were engaging in
legitimate political discourse on
january 6th and mccarthy literally runs
away when we say rachel scott caught up
with him we're not using the term
metaphorically she literally ran and
caught up with him so i'm going to play
this i understand if you're just
listening today the visual element is is
a big piece of it but mccarthy comes
around the corner this guy hasn't run
this fast since he had to run away from
the rioters on january 6th comes around
the corner at a gallop
uh and then rachel scott tries to talk
to him and he just says it's not good to
answer questions in hallways you guys
understand this hallways acoustically
are terrible for answering questions you
really want to be answering questions in
the bathroom that's exactly where
questions should be asked and answered
look at this
look at this guy he just takes that
corner uh you know if this were a
motorcycle race he probably would have
lost traction coming around that corner
um it's it's not good to answer
questions in the hallway and telling
rachel scott to make an appointment uh
she did and so far uh she attended to
make an appointment and so far it has
not been uh granted mccarthy is the
prototypical epitome
of the politician
with no redeeming qualities whatsoever
on policy he's a disaster
uh on optics and his relationship with
the media he's a disaster on having any
kind of actual sort of like guiding
principles
as an individual ethical principles
moral principles completely and totally
vapid and
just
the epitome of the
gross dc politician and here turning the
corner and running away a very bad day
for kevin mccarthy starting by saying
the writers were engaging in legitimate
political discourse then everything
going haywire mcconnell turning around
and saying
legitimate political discourse it was an
insurrection guys that's what it was
just not going super well for kevin
mccarthy and what you have to understand
is that this is not really
a departure
from how most of these people operate
they clearly have private
sincerely held beliefs about what
happened on january 6th and i continue
to believe
most of their beliefs about what
happened on january 6th
are that trump caused it and it was
terrible and it was disgusting i i
genuinely think most of them believe
that maybe marjorie taylor green doesn't
you know maybe lauren beau bear doesn't
or madison cawthorne maybe they liked it
but most of these republicans know trump
incited it and it was objectively a
disaster for the republican party even a
lot of the media people know it hannity
we know from the texts sean hannity knew
it was a disaster but publicly he had to
put a different spin on it but publicly
they continue some to struggle some not
to seem to struggle and just say it was
all fine and it was peaceful and all
this different stuff
uh and for as long as they continue that
it reinforces this idea that they have
no actual
concern with anything other than
self-preservation for their own seats
and self-preservation for the republican
party that's all they care about at the
end of the day if you've been if you're
listening today and you didn't see the
clips i played including kevin mccarthy
running away we'll have them on our
instagram you can find us at david
pakman show on instagram see the clips
let me know what you think
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow alright this is a
fascinating story about how backwards
the american right wing currently is i
know many of you have been following the
controversy
with podcast host joe rogan i've been on
the rogan program two times i've also
spent the last year calling out lots of
the misinformation that has been
divulged on the joe rogan program
initially the controversy with joe rogan
was over coveted disinformation
including multiple guests making
outrageous claims about vaccines and
covid which i couldn't possibly list now
but it led to numerous musical artists
including neil young and joni mitchell
and others to pull their music from
spotify and it led to joe rogan putting
out a statement about the coveted
misinformation saying
i'm not trying to spread disinformation
i'm not trying to be controversial
and i'm going to make an effort to have
more people on with what we might
consider sort of like the mainline
medical science views and some people
felt the apology was forced some people
felt the apollo apology was disingenuous
some people liked it etc shortly after
the covet disinformation controversy
a compilation video of rogan using the
n-word on his show from the last decade
plus came out and it was a whole new
controversy including the artist india
ari
saying i'm pulling my music from spotify
and rogan doing another apology video
saying listen when i watch this stuff
um it's it's not good i recognize it's
not good and
i didn't have racist intent and okay he
did another apology some people didn't
like the apology some people liked the
apology others said this is the right
thing to say other said this is the
wrong thing to say the content of it is
not actually at issue here what is
fascinating is that the right is now
turning on rogan
because he apologized because he
apologized
early on in this controversy the right
were the defenders of rogan saying it's
great that he's putting out their
alternative views about coveting
vaccines even if they're completely not
based in fact uh this is a guy who you
know the don't cancel the the race the
use of the n-word is fine it's all fine
rogan's great great great take 100
million bucks to come to rumble we
learned yesterday all this different
stuff
but now that rogan has apologized
and i'll be honest i think the apologies
are sincere it doesn't mean anything in
particular about rogan's intent when he
said the stuff i have no idea but i do
think his apologies are sincere at least
as far as he feels today now the right
is turning on rogan
first and foremost donald trump putting
out a statement saying joe rogan is an
interesting and popular guy
but he's got to stop apologizing to the
fake news and radical left maniacs and
lunatics how many ways can you say
you're sorry joe just go about what you
do so well and don't let them make you
look weak and frightened that's not you
and it never will be so trump not
pleased with the apologies but still
sort of deferential to rogan but then
all sorts of conservative media and
elected officials
saying rogan is wrong to apologize let's
look first at a clip of florida governor
ron desantis saying no no no the apology
is bad mob will come after people and
they're targeting rogan because he's
threatening to upset the apple cart on
some of the things that they're holding
dear and with covet he's just bringing
opposing views he's letting people
decide they say he's against vaxx i've
not listened to a show but then i read
he specifically advocated for people
with comorbidities and elderly to get
vaccinated and so a lot of this is just
i think he's got a huge audience uh i
think a lot of the legacy outlets and i
think the left fear the fact that he can
reach so many people and so they're out
to destroy him but now the funny thing
is rogan's audience by most estimates is
down 50 since he moved to spotify so
this fear about the audience is kind of
a weird thing but okay desantis says the
apology was wrong and trump says the
apology was wrong but then
look at what is happening on other
conservative media outlets here is
stephen crowder weighing in on the
apology stuff um
i'm not going to lie i'm i was upset yes
i was angry with no with joe as well uh
and i'll explain to you why i'm more
angry of course with the people who've
tried to yeah i hate to use the term
cancel culture but the people who have
tried to destroy his life and his
livelihood now joe rogan is bigger than
them so good for him it shouldn't affect
him i hope he understands the power that
he has unfortunately he's caved a little
bit and i just
it that makes it harder for everybody
else and i have a lot of respect for joe
i think he's a good guy i've spent some
time with him i just so it's always hard
for me just full disclosure to be
objective when i know somebody so anyway
there's stephen crowder stephen crowder
says joe rogan caved
then we go next to steve bannon trump
propagandist steve bannon also not
pleased
let's listen to him
okay welcome you're in the war room it's
monday 7 february the year overlord 2022
now with closing in
almost 140
million um
downloads on the podcast and i just want
to add we did that without uh spotify
and we did that without groveling to
spotify uh-oh more on spotify in the
weeks days and weeks ahead
uh but it is uh it is amazing
uh and note to joe rogan the more you
grovel
the more episodes they're going to take
down the more so joe rogan being
admonished by steve bannon for groveling
and then we also have glenn beck glenn
beck doesn't like
what rogan has done
and i think the audio comes in him first
of all joe
never apologize and i don't mean it like
never apologize
when you've done something that you find
offensive or wrong
you should always apologize when
you
uh have done something that you're
ashamed of so
apology accepted apology uh warranted
perhaps perhaps maybe i if you were
using it in context i don't think so but
maybe should joe biden apologize for
what he said in that in that car i don't
i mean i don't think so no i know he was
quoting someone that's that's i am
giving i i don't know every word that
joe rogan has said on the podcast so
maybe he has thrown it out there you
know 12 years ago
context you know what i mean i i don't
know so i'm giving him the benefit of
the doubt and saying
you know if that was what happened
then you should apologize but not to
these people not to these people
if you really did hurt and offend people
with it
your audience would have told you that
you wouldn't be as successful as you are
now this is just it's just kind of weird
it's a weird argument that glenn beck
makes because
he wasn't as well known at the time that
he
did the segments that became part of
that compilation so i don't you know the
question i the better question would be
if you said that stuff now
what would be the reaction from your
much bigger audience and i think it's
very clear that much of the current
audience would be offended so anyway the
point here is what has gotten the right
to now say joe you're groveling joe
you're doing the wrong thing
is that he has apologized an apology
that i know many in my audience think is
completely insincere you know i've i've
said this idea that that that an apology
is not warranted here
um seems bizarre to me and of course if
you believe that he was forced by
spotify to apologize in order to keep
his show
that would be a reason to think the
apology is disingenuous uh but it
doesn't appear to be the case spotify
has said we're keeping rogan we've
pulled some episodes because of some of
the content but we like rogan we're
keeping broken and um it is amazing how
what has triggered the right is you know
a dozen uses of the n-word no they're
fine with that
total out and out coveted disinformation
from guests that rogan doesn't challenge
they say no he's giving alternate views
that's that's totally fine the apology
has catalyzed and coalesced trump
desantis stephen crowder stephen bannon
glenn beck and others who i'm not
playing today to say now rogan is doing
the wrong thing the apology
is now
the wrong thing
these people are truly incredible and it
just reminds us
these are not good uh counterparts to
any kind of real discussions
about solving problems
on the planet that affect humans
and moving forward in a productive way
they they're just not good faith actors
this video is
it's an snl skit except it's actually
not
as many of you know
there has been this canadian trucker
convoy
and it has been
infected by but also to some degree
organized by a radical extremist fringe
the big picture of what's going on in
canada and we interviewed lance from the
serfs on a live stream earlier this week
about it
90 this is according to lance 90
of canadian truckers are vaccinated but
there is so i guess in theory some of
that 90 but really mostly from the 10
that is unvaccinated
they want to end
vaccine mandates now
a reasonable question would be well
which mandates because there's there are
provincial vaccine mandates in canada
in many many provinces but also to truck
to the united states the u.s requires
proof of vaccination even if you get
your province to say you don't need to
be vaccinated to to do your trucking to
the u.s you'd still need to be
vaccinated just one of the many
questions here and one of the things
about it is that obviously not all the
truckers who don't want the mandates are
racist obviously obviously obviously but
some of the organizers have a history of
white nationalism and racism we heard
from the canadian anti-hate network who
says we are calling this a far-right
convoy
because from day one the organizers
themselves are part of the far right
they've been previously involved in
far-right movements they've made
islamophobic comments in the past etc
etc so this is i mean you you can't
script this any better
jesse waters newly minted as the host of
uh i think maybe the seven o'clock hour
jesse waters now has a show daily on fox
he wanted to prove how not racist the
truckers are
so he finds a freedom convoy trucker
named saba vizi
and brings him on to prove how not
racist the truckers are
and the trucker says i'm not racist i
have colored friends
guys it's
it's it's
it's beyond parody
take a look at this it sounds like like
an snl skit it was only one guy
so
we are not racist
i have
all type of friends
color friends spanish chinese you know
they are great people
there is no racism here
guys
i don't know
if he has colored friends how racist
could he really be
it's it's beyond parody
now to be fair
he clearly speaks english as a second
language
so the use of the word colored could be
a language issue
but the optics are absurd and that being
said even if the use of the word colored
comes from english being a second
language
the concept of i'm not racist because i
have black friends
at this point could not possibly be more
cliche
so
jesse waters looking to prove
how not racist the truckers are
and coming up with this bizarre bizarre
appearance that could just as easily
have been from saturday night live
or mad tv uh the truckers are still
going they're still going in canada
they're honking horns and doing doing
other things
and my expectation is that probably in
the next week or so it'll all
start to wind down i don't believe
they're going to have any success
in uh eliminating the vaccine mandates
that's my sense as of right now if you
expect them to
have any achievements as far as that
goes
let me know i want to hear from you
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
we're really learning a ton this week
about how you can uh lie with graphs lie
with charts lie with statistics and
we're learning all of it from from fox
news earlier this week i showed you um a
completely deceptive chart which
presented the opposite of the truth with
regard to america's healthiest and
unhealthiest cities that was earlier
this week today i'm going to show you a
clip which is really a master class in
how to deceptively use statistics
um tucker carlson hosted
charlie kirk on his program charlie kirk
is sort of like a right-wing
um
indoctrinator of college kids i guess is
the way i would say it through an
organization called turning point usa
now charlie kirk has no medical
knowledge or expertise whatsoever
and he appeared on the tucker carlson
program and argued that vaccines might
increase deaths covet vaccines might
increase deaths now before we even start
the clip i'm going to remind you that
that's not true
it's not true
but look at how they frame the data
to create that possibility okay let's
listen here
so here's a shocking story look you
should care no matter what side you're
on above all about how americans are
doing and one of the main measures of
how they're doing is how long they live
if you're dying younger there's a
problem and a lot of them are dying
younger
this fact comes to us from the life
insurance companies which keep close
track of that and notice this according
to their data according to scott
davidson the ceo of one america
insurance reported deaths in the age
range by the way no no
one america insurance doesn't have
anything to do with one american news
just just so everybody's clear
18 to 64 those the working years were up
40
in the third quarter of last year
compared to pre-pandemic and pre-vaccine
totals now remember 18 to 64. that's an
important aspect of this
we are seeing right now the highest
death rates we have seen in the history
of this business not just at one america
40 is just unheard of and again these
are the guys who do this for a living
and they're shocked
so the question
what's causing this it's clear our
leaders don't think kovid is to blame
here's stacey abrams masculist in front
of a room full of mass children and she
has at least one very obvious
comorbidity here's barack obama
masculist in the face of his masked
servants as they build his latest
mansion in hawaii
so if corona is not causing these deaths
and it's not
what is causing these deaths forty
percent increase
charlie kirk is the co-founder of
turning point usa to sort of piece on
this that's why first of all why on
earth would you have charlie kirk on to
talk about this it makes no sense at all
we learned about it he joins us tonight
to assess charlie kirk thanks so much
for coming on what is this thank you
we don't know i mean the one business
that actually tells the truth regarding
the death of americans is life insurance
they have to get this right they have
entire teams of actuaries that study
this data all day long it's not the
public health authorities that are
warning this it's a single ceo of a
major life insurance company says hey by
the way there's kind of a 40 increase in
death 10 he said would be a once in 200
year catastrophe we have a 40 increase
in death and it's not because of covet
and we deserve answers and what's so
amazing tucker is that we've known this
information and this data for a couple
weeks now
where are the politicians where are the
leaders where the people we put in
charge to actually care about the
well-being of our people well at least
we know how many times joe rogan used a
bad word in a podcast the last 10 years
i guess we're getting our pronouns right
for our six year olds but we have a 40
increase in death amongst the supposed
healthiest portion of the american
population this is a catastrophe we
deserve answers and some would
conjecture hey does this have something
to do with the fact that we might have
done a mass inoculation strategy we know
that there was deaths of alienation
suicide and otherwise but there's no
answers no one's talking about it
so i mean isn't this the primary number
they should be focused on if you're in
charge of the well-being of the american
people and the death rate jumps by 40
percent in a cohort
you know that's not supposed to die
young
then like why aren't you hair on fire
upset about it i'm honestly confused
well it's either they don't care or they
don't know how to talk about it or they
are too concerned about gdp numbers or
stock market increases or immigration
quotas or whatever it's a mass casualty
event it's that simple and the fact that
the insurance company so listen this
this is really uh a master class in
deceptive use of
um of statistics so so you really have
to break this down in parts
kovidvac he talks about the mass
inoculation campaign maybe something we
need to look at here
covet vaccines protect you from covet
death they're very very good at that
but they say well
vaccines happened
and deaths went up
what's going on maybe the vaccines are
part of this
you have to critically analyze the
primary sources and when you do you
realize that this has been studied
extensively first of all it is the right
that loves to say
a lot of the people that supposedly died
of covid
didn't really die of covid they died of
something else now you and i have
already discussed well
um kovid can
cause someone to die
due to some intervening or intermediate
condition
covid in many of the people that die
triggers
a separate illness that eventually leads
to death uh it can cause cardiac issues
it can cause respiratory issues it can
all sorts of different things they are
the ones who were telling us a lot of
the people supposedly dying of cove that
aren't really dying of cove they're
dying about other stuff here they're
some of those people are in these
statistics some of these people are the
people that the right wingers have been
saying they shouldn't be classifying as
dying of covid because they're actually
technically dying of other stuff well
that's what you're seeing in the data
when they say even not counting covet
you see these people dying it's the
people you've been talking about that
didn't quote really die of covet that's
one piece of this
second piece of this we know
that due to two things one for a while
all non-emergency care being delayed in
the health care system and number two
because a lot of people say i don't want
to go to a medical facility right now
i've got that ache i've got that symptom
i don't i'm going to delay this
screening or that
that screening we know that conditions
for example like cancer are on average
being diagnosed later when you diagnose
cancer later
the
treatment options are more limited
they're less likely to be effective and
your death rate is going to be up so
that's also a real thing here and the
irresponsibility of saying i don't know
the mass inoculation campaign we got to
be thinking about it is not only
irresponsible
uh but i think they even know that it's
not true i don't think there's any way
charlie kirk i don't know
but tucker carlson there's no way tucker
carlson thinks that the reason the death
rate is up is because of vaccination
there's just no way and they're jumping
around through it's not even they're
jumping three steps ahead they're just
jumping three steps in any direction and
connecting things for which there are
not actually connections and it's
irresponsible and it's part of the
continued disinformation that is being
spread on fox news
speaking of fox news one other just
little fox news story this this is just
kind of a funny thing
greg gutfeld is a fox host
and he's going to be taping some shows
in person
and if you want to go and be in the
audience you're going to have to show
proof of vaccination now you might be
saying well david maybe the venue
requires it
doesn't appear to be the case this is
very interesting um media matters
has this uh the story
gut failed and his fox news colleagues
have repeatedly criticized vaccine
requirements
fox news and host greg gutfeld are
putting on a week of shows in texas that
require attendees to show proof of
vaccination or a negative covid test
gutfeld and his colleagues have
repeatedly derided covet requirements
fox will be taping the weekday program
gutfeld at gilles dallas between
february 21 and 25 the event page for
the shows says quote proof of
vaccination or a negative coveted test
taken within 48 hours of the show will
be required for admittance
um
some other upcoming shows at gilles
dallas do not appear to have vaccination
or testing requirements for entry so it
is not a requirement of the state
and it is not a requirement of the venue
now it's fine for them to do this but
why are they deriding such
requirements and measures
constantly
on their programs
gut felt like many of his fox
corporation colleagues is vaccinated
still that hasn't stopped the network's
personalities from frequently
criticizing vaccines and attacking
pro-public health measures like vaccine
requirements for example gutfeld said
last august in new york city bill de
blasio introduced a vaccine passport the
new passport system calls for showing
proof of backs to enter gyms restaurants
and entertainment venues which judging
by the stats i just mentioned
effectively bans most blacks just like
the dems did to them during the jim crow
days so who is the hitler now if 70
percent of black new yorkers are
vaccinated they're the ones getting
banned talk about white privilege folks
how do you take these people seriously
when they're telling people covet
protocols are bad and discriminatory and
then they choose to enact the very same
covet protocols the very same coveted
protocols that they
say are racist in some cases
and then this the state of texas doesn't
require it gillies dallas doesn't appear
to require it because other shows don't
have these requirements
but the gutfeld show requires it and i
agree with it
i agree with it but the important point
here is not only are they hypocrites
they are hypocrites in a way that is bad
for public health until it affects them
personally
gut felt probably doesn't want to be
around on vaccinated people it could be
as simple as that at the end of the day
that this comes down to uh it's just
pathetic it's pathetic and i don't think
that they're going to change they're
going to continue
saying what they need to say to placate
their audience
but then doing what they know they
actually need to do to be safe and to
keep themselves safe not surprising
we have a voicemail number that you can
call any time of day that number is
2192davidp this is a really interesting
voicemail this caller is a mental health
professional now i know some of you are
going to hear the name amanda love and
you're going to say that's the joke you
know it's the joke it's a man to love no
this is really this person's name we
made sure that this is really a mental
health professional we found that they
are a licensed mental health
professional in their state
they are weighing in on what i said
about at what point do we see these
delusional trumpists and say not to
excuse their behavior
and not to ridicule mental illness at
what point do we say this is mental
illness
and amanda who called in and works in
this field has
very interesting insights about it take
a listen to this
hi david my name's amanda love and i'm a
mental health professional i just wanted
to follow up with you about um when
you're showing the trump um supporters
and asking whether they might be
actually mentally ill
and yeah some of what i saw could be
classified as delusional
which is um caused under the psychotic
realm of mental illness
some delusions are fixed and
pretty much impossible to eradicate even
with medication indeed so yeah i'm
keeping a close eye on that too because
some of it is definitely mentally ill
people that we're dealing with
in which case you know they're not being
treated or
whatever that case may be
but i appreciate everything you do and i
love all the information that you're
putting out there so thanks for what you
do
and i'll keep watching thank you so
listen amanda is not i know i'll get
emails david amanda shouldn't really be
diagnosing anybody over the internet
amanda's not diagnosing anybody what
she's talking about is that generally
speaking some of the beliefs of these
trump supporters are what we would call
delusional beliefs these are these are
delusional people that falls under the
general category of psychosis and uh as
someone who you know i've many mental
health professionals in
my family from
um
licensed mental health counselors
psychologists and psychiatrists
a lot of these beliefs are very
resistant to revision
uh
from
treatment with medication and even even
from psychotherapy these these can be
very stubborn and recalcitrant types of
beliefs now i think it is important to
mention
that a lot of these trump people you
know they believe uh
the q anon stuff they believe
joe biden was killed and replaced with a
body double they believe you know all of
this different stuff okay
with a lot of these people
it just so happens that their beliefs
relate to trump and many of these folks
absent trump if trump didn't exist if
trump hadn't been president and it
didn't start all of this this chain of
events that has taken place over the
last five to six years
many close to seven years now many of
these people would still have delusional
beliefs but they'd be about something
else
and this is something we've talked about
with experts on
um cultish behavior conspiracism and
believers and conspiracy theories
typically these are folks who are prone
to these beliefs and it's just sort of
like what's in their environment that
they get fixated on and that's why you
see sometimes the flat earth people also
believe the jewish conspiracies
illuminati
and vaccine microchips and and on and on
and on because it's the same types of
folks who are often prone or susceptible
to these types of beliefs so very
interesting voicemail from amanda we're
not diagnosing any particular individual
here
just amanda's general assessment of the
delusional nature of some of these folks
this is not like and and i think you
know to to really underline the
difference here
there is a difference between believing
cutting taxes for the rich is good for
the economy right there's you can
massage data to make that case and then
i can say no but the date is inaccurate
for this
if you believe joe biden was killed and
replaced with a body double in order to
steal the election from trump
that is different there is a major
difference between oh i disagree with
you on tax policy and you think biden's
an imposter because the real biden was
killed those are not equivalent in any
way and there's a difference between a
political disagreement
and some of these delusional beliefs
speaking of delusional beliefs on the
bonus show today it looks like florida
governor ron desantis is signaling that
he would support a so-called don't say
gay bill it's been years since we've
talked about these don't say gay bills
and they're they're vile and we're going
to talk about it also a record 31
million americans will be betting on the
super bowl am i one of them
um
most of you probably know the answer but
i'll answer it on the bonus show and
also there is an 85 mile wide comment
heading in our direction from the oort
cloud not going to hit earth not gonna
i'm not gonna you know i know that there
are some people who for the bonus show
they would do really dishonest things oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad right i'm not
going to do that i'm not going to
pretend maybe this comet is going to hit
us it's not but it's an interesting
story nonetheless so all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up now
at joinpackman.com
you can use the coupon code wow 22 for a
discount and i will see you then